Let's review the Calvin
cycle a little bit.
Maybe I'm going to go into a
little bit more detail than
the last video.
And by doing that, we'll be
able to appreciate an
inefficiency, or what we think
is an inefficiency that occurs
in many photosynthetic plants.
So just to review the Calvin
cycle, you start
off with some CO2.
In the last video, I had six
molecules of CO2 and six
molecules of ribulose
bisphosphate.
But in this one, just to show
you that I could have
literally just divided that last
cycle by two, I'm going
to start with three and three.
Three molecules of
carbon dioxide.
Three molecules of ribulose
bisphosphate.
If you don't remember what
ribulose bisphosphate was, it
was just a 5-carbon molecule.
It had two phosphates on it.
I can draw the phosphates.
So you have a phosphate there.
And you have a phosphate
there.
And we saw on the last video--
and here I'm going to do a
little bit more detail.
Of course carbon dioxide,
there's only one carbon.
I can just draw a carbon
like that.
I mean, I don't want to draw
the oxygens right now.
I just want to focus on just
the carbons and maybe the
phosphates.
But in the last video we saw
that these two merged.
Or these two reacted.
They reacted in the presence
of ribulose bisphosphate
carbocylase, which
is this enzyme.
It was that big protein that I
showed you in the last video.
And it's called RuBisCo
for short.
So I'm going to write RuBisCo
in the middle
of this whole cycle.
Because all of this is going
on with the RuBisCo enzyme.
These molecules are joining on
to the RuBisCo enzyme and then
the ATP and the NADHs are
reacting on different parts.
And that's essentially what's
driving the whole reaction.
So you have all of this is
happening with that big
RuBisCo protein, or enzyme, or
whatever you want to call it.
And this just stands for
ribulose bisphosphate
carboxylate.
So it essentially telling you
that it merges a carbon onto
ribulose bisphosphate.
And the last video, I just did
a very hand-wavey, I didn't
show you all of the
intermediates.
But I showed you, look, if in
this situation you end up
using six ATPs and six NADHs,
you'll end up with
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
Or G3P.
Or that's also called
phosphoglyceraldehyde so you
can also write it as PGAL.
But a very easy way to visualize
it as just a
3-carbon chain with
a phosphate.
With a phosphate group.
And the last video when I
started with six carbon
dioxides and six ribulose
bisphosphates.
And I ended up with
12 of these.
Now I have three and three.
Now I'm going to end up
with six of these.
So I'm going to end
up with six G3Ps.
And the math works out, right?
I have three carbons plus three
times five carbons.
That's a total of 18 carbons.
And here I have six times
three carbons.
Or 18 carbons.
And that's what I showed you in
the last video, but there
are actually some intermediary
steps.
So the very first thing that's
actually formed is
3-phosphoglycerate.
And the whole reason why I'm
showing you this detail, and
maybe you're taking a biology
class where they actually go
into this level of details, is
I want to show that this
compound also gets produced in
that inefficient cycle that
we're going to explore
in this video.
So you get 3-phosphoglycerate,
which is
also a 3-carbon chain.
But it's a different
one than this.
And this isn't ready to produce
glucose just yet.
But you could also imagine that
as a 3-carbon chain with
a phosphate group.
And then, and course you're
going to produce six of these.
Just to make sure all the carbon
gets accounted for.
You have 18 carbons here, you
have 18 carbons here.
So you're going to
have six of these
3-phosphoglycerates get produced.
And then each of those gets
a phosphate from ATP.
So you're going to have
six ATPs come in.
Remember these ATPs got
produced in the light
dependent reactions that occur
in the membrane of our
thylakoids.
Anyway, we have these ATPs.
You have six ATPs.
And then they become six ADPs.
So essentially they have given
away their phosphate groups.
So they're going to give one
phosphate group to each of
these six 3-phosphoglycerates.
And then you're going to end
up with this, right here.
I'm running out of space.
Maybe I didn't do it as neatly
as I should have.
But you're going to end up with
this three chain carbon,
or 3-carbon compound.
It's going to have two
phosphates then.
And this, you could
know the name.
This is 1 3-bisphosphoglycerate.
This was just
3-phosphoglycerate, which
means that the phosphate
is on the third carbon.
Now we have 1
3-bisphophoglycerate.
We have a phosphate on the
1-carbon and the 3-carbon.
We have two of them.
So it's bisphosphoglycerate.
So that's to get
us right there.
And then to get from the 1
3-biposphoglycerate, and of
course we have six
of these as well.
Six of these turn into
six of these.
And to turn these six 1
3-phosphoglycerate into our
three glyceraldehyde
3 phosphates, or
phosphoglyceraldehyde the
names are very daunting.
This is where we're actually
going to oxidize our NADPH.
Remember oxidizing is losing
electrons or losing hydrogens
with their electrons,
either way.
So here, on this step right
here, two things are going to
happen, actually.
You're going to have six NADPHs
become six NAD pluses.
So they're losing that hydrogen
and the electrons.
And also one phosphate is going
to be lost from each of
these molecules.
And then you're going to
also have plus six of
the phosphate groups.
The phosphate groups don't
get lost here.
They get added onto these
molecules right there.
And then we end up with our
sixth glyceraldehyde
3-phosphates, which we learned
in the last video, we can then
use to produce fuel or
glucose or other
carbohydrates in the cell.
But we also learned that this
is called the Calvin cycle.
So all of it doesn't get used
to produce actual glucose or
other carbohydrates.
Most of it, out of the six, five
of them are going to be
used to produce our three
ribulose bisphosphates.
So let me do it like this.
So you're going to have five
G3Ps go in that direction.
So for every six G3Ps you
produce, five go back into the
cycle and then one
exits the cycle.
We saw this in the last video.
In the last video I had 12
here, so 10 went in this
direction and two in
this direction.
I'm just dividing everything
by two in this video.
And the whole reason why I
multiplied by two in the last
video is so that we end up
with two going into this
direction because two
is enough to produce
at least one glucose.
But we don't have to have two.
We could just say we do this
whole cycle twice to get two.
But anyway, I have one
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
coming out of this end.
And then these five
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphates
that stay in the cycle.
Remember those are
just 3-carbons
with a phosphate group.
I drew it over here already.
They will then use another
three ATP.
So we end up with three ADPs.
And the phosphate groups
actually end up on the
ribulose bisphosphate and they
get essentially recycled into
ribulose bisphosphate for the
whole cycle to happen again.
Remember when all this is
happening you can kind of
imagine in or on the surface
of this big enzyme.
This ribulose bisphosphate
carboxylase.
And actually, just so you know
a piece of terminology, this
type of photosynthesis is called
C3 photosynthesis.
And the whole reason why it's
called C3 photosynthesis is
because the very first product
that you get when you react
with carbon dioxide, when the
first time you fix your carbon
dioxide-- remember carbon
dioxide fixation is when you
take it in its gaseous
form and you actually
put it into a molecule.
The very first carbon molecule
you get once the carbon
dioxide gets fixed is
a 3-carbon molecule.
It's phosphoglycerate.
That's why I showed
it to you there.
Because that's where
the three in the C3
photosynthesis comes from.
Now, everything I've just done
is a review of what we did in
the last video.
Maybe with a little
bit more detail.
And I showed you that you
don't have to start
with six and six.
You could start with three and
three and just have five go
down here and one go down
here instead of doubling
everything.
But what I want to show you now
is an inefficiency that
goes on in plants.
This RuBisCo doesn't
necessarily
just fix carbon dioxide.
It can also react with oxygen.
And actually, its name is
ribulose bisphosphate
carboxylase oxygenase, which
means it can react
with carbon or oxygen.
And this mechanism-- so let's
say you have your ribulose
bisphosphate hanging around.
You know we're in the stroma
of our chloroplast.
So let's say we have our five
ribulose bisphosphates.
And instead of reacting with
carbon it can actually react
with oxygen.
So instead of having carbon
dioxide here, I can have O2
coming in here.
We have oxygen coming in here.
And all of this, once again, is
occurring on the surface or
with the assistance
of the RuBisCo.
The exact same, the
RuBisCo enzyme.
Ribulose bisphosphate
carboxylase oxygenase.
That's why.
Because it can also
fix oxygen.
And when these two things react,
you don't get useful
things that can be used for
fuel and all of that.
You end up with-- and my drawing
is a little messy--
you end up with-- well when
these two guys react-- you'll
end up with five molecules
of this guy right here.
Five molecules of this
3-phosphoglycerate right there.
Remember here we ended
up with six of them.
But now we're only going
to end up with five
phosphoglycerates.
I know the names are
all very confusing.
But the basic idea is to
remember that what's happening
here is if carbon dioxide isn't
getting fixed, oxygen
can get fixed.
And you end up with five
phosphoglycerates.
And you actually also end up
with five-- this is called
phosphoglycolate.
I know these are very
daunting names.
Phosphoglycolate, which is
a 2-carbon molecule.
Which makes sense because we
only have five carbons to
start with.
This thing right here is
a 3-carbon molecule.
That's a 3-carbon molecule
and this right here
is a 2-carbon molecule.
So this right here is going to
be a 2-carbon molecule and it
has a phosphate group.
So as you can imagine, in this
situation we're not going to
be able to keep going forward
and produce our glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate, which we can then
use to make up carbohydrates.
We're stuck.
We just have these five
phosphoglycerates.
These can go on and some
percentage of them, but the
ratios are all getting
messed up.
But everything doesn't
necessarily happen this
cleanly in the cell.
These things can go on, but we
have one less being produced.
And this thing right here, it's
actually using up some of
our carbon from our ribulose
bisphosphate.
And if this thing kept going
up, all of our ribulose
bisphosphate is going
to get eaten up.
We're not going to be able to
continue on into this cycle
over and over again.
And actually this is kind
of a waste product.
Right here this is
a waste product.
Or we think it's a
waste product.
And this actually has to exit
your chloroplast and actually
get processed by other
organelles in the plant cells.
And these are called, these
waste processing organelles in
your cells, these are
peroxisomes I know there's a
lot of complicated
terminology here.
But the important thing to
remember, when RuBisCo fixes
oxygen, this is actually called
photorespiration.
That's an important
word to know.
Photorespiration.
All of a sudden, instead of
being able to carry forward
with your Calvin cycle and
produce a lot of sugar,
instead you are depleting
your RuBisCo.
So this is a very bad process.
This is going to get in the
way of your Calvin cycle.
And remember how important
each of these G3Ps are.
Because for every turn of the
Calvin cycle, or at least the
way I did it, we only produce
one G3P that actually gets
used for something useful.
The other five G3Ps have to go
back to produce ribulose
bisphosphate.
RuBisCo of course
is the enzyme.
So in this situation we only
have five phosphoglycerates to
begin with.
Maybe if we have our ATP or an
NADH, we can convert these
five-- and it doesn't have to
go in this direction-- but
maybe we can convert these five
phosphoglycerates into
five glyceraldehyde
3-phosphates.
G3Ps.
Then all of these are going to
be used back to produce our
ribulose bisphosphate.
So to go from here to here,
we actually had to
use up ATP and NADH.
And then to go from here to
here, we have to use more ATP.
But we went through this whole
cycle and we didn't produce
anything, in terms of useful
things that can be used to--
essentially sugars or
carbohydrates that can be used
to fuel or provide structure
for the plant in any way.
So this is a completely--
or we think-- this
is a wasteful process.
So people wonder, when you
look a lot of biological
systems you don't see wasteful
processes all the time.
You would say, well wouldn't
natural selection have
selected against this?
And some people believe that
this is just a remnant from
our evolutionary past, or our
plants' evolutionary past,
where there wasn't a lot of
oxygen in the atmosphere.
And if there wasn't a lot of
oxygen in the atmosphere, this
was not that likely
of an occurrence.
But there's some people who
actually believe that no, this
might actually have
been selected
for in natural selection.
Because if there is a lot of
oxygen hanging around in the
cell, more than you need, that
oxygen might actually react
with your ATP and create other
harmful compounds in the cell.
And this might be a way of
sopping up the harmful oxygen
that's actually hanging
around the cell.
So who knows?
But it's interesting idea.
That you have this one enzyme
that can react with ribulose
bisphosphate and
carbon dioxide.
And if that happens, we just get
our regular Calvin cycle.
Or it can react with ribulose
bisphosphate and oxygen and
actually fix oxygen into
these two molecules.
Especially the phosphoglycolate
which we
think is a waste compound.
And if you just went on and on
in the Calvin cycle in this
way, you will not produce
any useful sugars.
So in the next video, what I
want to do is study some
plants that have been
able to get by this
photorespiration problem.
And you could imagine,
photorespiration could be a
really big deal or it could be
very harmful in situations
where, one, it's very important
for a plant to be
very productive of sugars.
And it can also, we'll see,
it can be a problem-- it's
definitely a problem if there's
a huge amount of
oxygen content.
But in the next video I'm going
to show you plants that
have gotten around this
problem by, instead of
performing C-3 photosynthesis,
which is the classic Calvin
cycle that I just showed
you, they perform C-4
photosynthesis.
And I'll show you what that
means in the next video.